[Musique]
je me trouve à la ferme de gally de
saint cyr l'école alors elle est connue
pour sa cueillette pour sa boutique pour
son café et également pour sa ferme
pédagogique
mais aujourd'hui elle a ouvert sa cave à
vin et je me trouvais que bruno gansel
bonjour bonjour au bout alors pourquoi
est ce que vous avez décidé d'ouvrir
cette cave avant du vin on en
commercialise au niveau de la boutique
depuis quelques années et on a souhaité
mettre en valeur le bâtiment qui se
trouve derrière nous et en faire une
cave à vins avec une offre de produits
beaucoup plus large que ce que l'on
retrouve actuellement dans le magasin
d'accord et du coup est ce que c'était
un peu une demande de vos clients ou une
envie d'étendre votre offre devant les
deux c'est à dire que comme je vous
l'expliquais dans le magasin où on vend
déjà du vin depuis quelques années il y
avait volonté de la clientèle de trouver
une offre un peu plus grande et puis
dans l'histoire de la famille l'euro qui
gère les fermes de gally il ya eu un
passé de vente de vin dans les années
50-60 où il y avait plein de points de
vente de vin dans la région parisienne
et dans paris intra muros est donc cette
thématique là et et cher à la famille
l'euro et donc on a voulu remettre au
goût du jour cette vente de deux
bouteilles de vin donc une manière dé
faire perdurer l'histoire exactement
c'est tout à fait ça il vous propose
qu'on aille découvrir à l'intérieur
allons-y
[Musique]
non
je me trouve avec florian du coup à
l'intérieur de cette nouvelle cave à
vins à gali bonjour bonjour est-ce que
vous pouvez nous présenter cette cave à
vin je crois qu'il ya 400 références
donc c'est assez énorme absolument on a
voulu en quelque sorte organiser la cave
en trois parties vous avez une section
apéro logis juste derrière vous d'accord
avec des vins plus destinés au repas
très simple aux apéritifs dînatoires
repas entre entre amis vous avez sur la
partie centrale une gamme un peu plus
élaboré sur des vins gastronomes pour
des repas un peu plus sérieux et sur la
droite du coût des vins de fête 20
prestige pour des occasions assez
spécifique d'accord donc plusieurs
plusieurs vins pour plusieurs occasions
ok c'était le but et le prix dans tout
ça on est environ dans quelle fourchette
de prix on démarre sur les 20 à 9 euros
la bouteille allant jusqu'à plus de 100
euros d'accord donc accessible mais
aussi aux diams tout à fait tout à fait
je voulais vous demander est ce que vous
faites de la dégustation quand vous
j'avais des clients qui vous demandent
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
faites oui depuis l'ouverture de la cave
on nous demande effectivement si nous
organisons des événements très
prochainement ça se fera d'accord nous
sommes en train de réfléchir sur
l'organisation
les thématiques seront variés on
pourrait très bien travaillé sur des
initiations à la dégustation ou
éventuellement faire un tour des
différentes régions viticoles
le choix peut être très très très large
écoute et merci beaucoup avec grand
plaisir merci à vous
[Musique]
la cave à vin de la ferme de gally est
ouverte du mercredi au dimanche de 10
heures à 19 heures je vous rappelle tout
de même que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé